The year was 1861.
Arthur Du Plessis, one of the world’s most
renowned explorers and adventurers, hacked
through the thick vines of the Amazon Rainforest
with a well-worn machete.
He grunted and strained, his clothes heavy
and skin slick with sweat.
He took a deep swig from his canteen and paused
briefly to breathe.
This was the second week of his solo expedition
into the Lung of the World, and the process
had been grueling.
He’d fought off piranhas, electric eels,
and invasive candiru fish while wading and
kayaking down the Amazon River.
He’d contended with tribesmen and poachers,
and narrowly dodged his fair share of poisonous
beasties that could take down prey three times
their size.
No sane man would brave this horror for its
own sake, but Arthur had as good a reason
as any: He was searching for his younger brother,
Joseph Du Plessis, who had disappeared a month
earlier during a trek through the Amazon.
Joseph had always admired his brother’s
wild adventures, and sought to imitate him.
It was for that very reason that Arthur had
felt responsible for his brother’s current
predicament, and made it his mission to rescue
him.
The Amazon is an ancient and cruel mistress.
The arrogant and foolish have hoped to conquer
or tame her for centuries, but countless men
had disappeared in the pulsing heart of this
green behemoth.
Arthur may have been a world-class explorer,
in a different league to many of the others
whose lives this green inferno had handily
taken, but there were creatures lurking deep
in the Amazon that went beyond even Arthur’s
knowledge.
The kind of beasts that would make the darkest
and most twisted nightmares look comparatively
inviting.
Beasts like SCP-2031.
If Joseph was able to send Arthur one more
message before it all came to a horrible end,
we could only imagine it’d be something
like “Don’t come looking for me.
It’s already too late.
But there’s still time to save yourself,
brother.
Stay away, for god’s sake, stay away.
You have no idea what you’re dealing with
here.
Forget about me.
Go while there’s still time.”
Sadly for Arthur Du Plessis, that time was
about to run out.
He ventured further into the depths of the
Amazon, where even light was scarce under
the thick canopy above.
A mighty green Anaconda slithered through
a nearby tributary, tongue flailing in search
of prey.
An Amazonian giant centipede - a centipede
so large and vicious it preys on snakes and
bats - skittered up a nearby
tree on 46 needle-like
legs.
A big, meaty tarantula deftly navigated the
branches above, while tree frogs with poison
potent enough to put an entire army six feet
under hopped through the rich undergrowth.
Humans held no power here.
Arthur fell to his knees and began to weep.
His foolish ambitions had gotten his dear
brother killed in this awful place.
Shot to death by poachers, strangled by anacondas,
or eaten alive by vicious bull sharks in the
Amazon river.
There were so many horrible ways that Joseph
could have died, and in the absence of ever
finding a body, all of them would simultaneously
be true.
The Du Plessis family would never know peace.
There would be a void, an emptiness, in all
of their hearts forever.
But just when Arthur was about to give up
hope, something miraculous happened: He saw
a human figure, stumbling around faintly in
the distance.
Arthur drew his trusty pistol, assuming it
could be a poacher or a hostile tribesman,
but something was different.
The figure had its back to Arthur, but he
recognized its shirt - a distinctive shade
of light blue.
Just like the shirt that Arthur had bought
for Joseph on his previous birthday.
Could it be?
Was this really him?
Arthur holstered his weapon and jumped to
his feet.
He couldn’t let this figure get away, even
if there was only the tiniest chance it could
actually be his brother and not some kind
of forest mirage.
Arthur ran towards the figure with the last
of his energy reserves, panting and wheezing.
He called his brother’s name again and again,
but the figure didn’t respond.
It just stumbled along, as though drunk.
But the closer Arthur got, the more certain
he was that this was indeed his brother.
The height, the hair, the clothes, the build.
It was Joseph Du Plessis, but why wasn’t
he responding?
Why wouldn’t he turn around?
As Arthur finally reached the figure, he ground
to a halt.
The most profound sense of dread fell over
him like a sudden monsoon.
Something unnatural, something truly terrible,
was about to happen, but he didn’t know
what - and moreover, it was too late to stop
now.
Feeling anxiety prickling up his legs and
back, Arthur reached forward to grab his brother
by the shoulder, the word “Joseph?”
trembling on his lips.
When Arthur’s hand touched Joseph’s shoulder,
he felt a fear greater than anything he’d
experienced before.
Something was moving beneath the skin of Joseph’s
shoulder.
Something writhing and alive, a million tiny
creatures all working together in his brother’s
flesh.
Before he could even draw his hand away, his
brother turned.
Or rather, the creatures that were wearing
his brother’s body turned around.
Arthur couldn’t help but scream at the horrible
sight before him.
His brother’s face looked loose and rotten,
aging skin hanging off of a rotten skull.
His jaw hung loose, no tongue inside.
No eyes, either.
Just millions of ants swarming in and out
of Joseph Du Plessis’ vacant, dead face.
The ants were huge and spiny, with long, curved
mandibles.
Eciton burchellii, a particularly hardy species
of New World Army Ant.
Arthur stepped back, babbling in terror at
what became of his brother.
The Joseph-suit stepped forward towards him,
and almost instinctively, Arthur pushed him
with both hands, feeling the nightmarish activity
swarming beneath the loose cover of Joseph’s
bony chest.
The Joseph-suit tumbled backward, tripping
over a rock, and burst.
There were no organs left inside his brother
now, they’d been eaten long ago.
It was just a thin tarpaulin of grey skin
over dry bones, and of course, millions upon
millions of ants, now making a beeline for
Arthur with the frightening military precision
any naturalist could expect
from Eciton burchellii.
But while army ants could be a formidable
and frightening foe in their own right, nobody
had seen any ants like this before.
Well, nobody who’d lived to tell the tale,
at least.
Arthur turned to flee, but sadly, it was already
too late for him.
What he thought were mere prickles of anxiety
were actually an invasion force of Eciton
burchellii soldiers, which had positioned
themselves over key nerves and ligaments on
his legs and spine.
As Arthur tried to run away, the ants began
to bite into him, cutting through skin, rending
bone, and munching into the chewy neurons
underneath.
Arthur felt intense flashes of pain all over
his body, before collapsing to the ground,
paralyzed.
That’s when the true horrors began.
If there was one consolation for Arthur in
the last terrible hours of his life, he would
at least know, first hand, exactly how his
brother died.
He couldn’t move, but he could feel everything.
The creatures chewed through the flesh of
his extremities, cutting holes in his skin
and creating openings for swarms of their
insect brethren to enter through.
Arthur felt like he was on fire as the swarm
entered his body, but was unable to do anything
about it.
Death by these creatures is a slow and torturous
experience.
Unlike their non-anomalous counterparts, the
swarms don’t immediately start devouring
all available soft tissue.
SCP-2031 want to keep their prey alive while
they renovate their new home.
Arthur finally died two days later - from
dehydration.
It was at this point that the creatures finally
began eating his organs and evenly distributing
their colony throughout his body.
The ants even produce an enzyme that slows
the decaying process for their deceased hosts.
That’s why Joseph Du Plessis didn’t look
a whole lot worse by the time Arthur found
him, even though he’d already suffered a
month of post-mortem infestation.
Not long after Arthur’s death, the Arthur-suit
got up and walked away.
The world would never know how or why Arthur
Du Plessis and his brother disappeared in
the dark heart of the Amazon jungle, but perhaps
for the sake of those who loved them, ignorance
is actually kinder than the truth.
It would be almost a century before the Foundation
finally discovered these creatures on a nearby
farm, designated them SCP-2031, and began
containment and testing.
They soon became aware of what Arthur, Joseph,
and many others had learned the hard way:
While they may be relatively
ineffectual individually,
together, these insects were a real force
to be reckoned with.
Very few non-anomalous animals had any chance
of escaping them once they’d set their sights
on a target and begun assuming their attack
positions.
In one observed instance, SCP-2031 soldiers
were able to take down a 1000kg Angus Bull
in five minutes, most of which was just spent
getting their soldiers into their proper positions
over the spine and leg ligaments.
The Foundation just got extremely lucky that
these vicious insect predators happened to
be isolated to some pretty specific areas
in South America, thanks
to the climate requirements
of their habitats.
In fact, pretty much all of the specimens
the Foundation found were all in one place.
The creatures had developed a particularly
frightening form of Ant Farm known as SCP-2031-A:
An isolated containment zone on a stretch
of farmland where the ants could find hosts
in the form of live people and animals, keeping
them relatively isolated.
Twenty-seven separate SCP-2031 colonies were
first found on this farm, inhabiting and operating
twenty-seven different corpses.
These included fifteen cows.
Five different horses.
Three domestic pigs.
One dog.
And most fascinating of
all, three human specimens:
An adult male, an adult female, and a child
of unspecified gender.
What’s even more fascinating than the efficacy
of these ants in attacking all different kinds
of prey is their deftness at mimicking the
behavior of their hosts.
This isn’t a Reconstructive Maggots situation
- see our video on that nightmare for further
information - the ants attempt to make their
hosts actually act like the creatures they
once were.
The Foundation were astonished to see that
the three human-suits seemed to actually go
through the motions of running the farm - watering
the “livestock,” dispensing feed, moving
other SCP-2031 colonies from one pasture to
another.
The human child-suit would even spend extensive
time playing with the dog-suit, engaging in
games such as fetch or mock wrestling.
How the SCP-2031 colonies are able to do this
is unknown - working theories include rigorous
observation of their targets before colonization,
and the colony hive mind somehow picking up
residual thoughts or muscle memory from their
victims.
Non-anomalous ants introduced to the SCP-2031
colonies also begin exhibiting anomalous traits,
so the effects may somehow be contagious.
One of the most fascinating moments of all
came when the structural integrity of the
dog-suit finally gave out, leading to its
colony exiting the body and returning to more
nomadic behavior typical of army ants in search
of a new host.
The strange part was that the human-suits
actually seemed to grieve for the deceased
dog-suit, with the child-suit becoming somewhat
distressed that their playmate was suddenly
gone.
The two adult human-suits even took the carcass
of the dog-suit and buried it in another pasture.
It was unlike anything the Foundation had
observed with SCP-2031 before.
At what point did mimicry become sincere behavior?
Because now, SCP-2031 was seriously blurring
the lines.
It is in the best interest of the Foundation
to keep this little ant farm going, both to
keep SCP-2031 distracted from venturing further
and causing trouble, and to further study
the fascinating behaviors and dynamics exhibited
by SCP-2031 colonies in captivity.
One of the researchers has already put in
a request for a new golden retriever.
Now go check out “SCP-2852 Sadistic Madman
Party Crasher | Cousin Johnny” and “SCP-5049
- The Skin Salesman - Demon Dan's Discount
Homunculus Depot” for more SCPs that’ll
give you utterly horrific fates!